I
hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast emerging role of liquid
biopsies and next-generation sequencing
for biomarker discovery my name is Jane
can elaborate and I'll be your moderator
for today's event today's educational
web seminar is presented by lab roots
the leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing scientific
collaboration and learning this webinar
is sponsored by kyochon hydrant offers
easy complete easy to implement sample
to inside solutions for next-generation
sequencing try an author to use the
industry's most reliable technology for
sample isolation because samples matter
to your success our top quality assays
and panels enable you to accurately
analyze and identify diseases and
genetic variations a bioinformatics
software such as by medical genomics
workbench and curated knowledge bases
such as IPA IPA from ingenuity transform
your raw data into relevant actionable
finding konjam is the only company today
that offers the complete sample to
inside solution partnering with hydrogen
your work can make a difference for more
information please visit www a comment
answers are welcome to you can do this
by hitting the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
and typing in your comments and
questions we'll try to answer as many
questions as you can and will follow up
with you if we don't have time for it
today if you want a better look you can
enlarge this live window by clicking on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see this presentation properly
let us know by clicking on the support
button at the top right or use the Q&A
button will make sure to resolve any
issues this is an educational webinar
unless offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the CD button located at the
bottom left hand corner of your web page
and follow the process of obtaining your
credit now let's get to today's
presenter we're proud to welcome Brian
tomorrow is tomorrow is
global product manager for
next-generation sequencing technologies
at kyochon with a focus on pre analytics
and targeted enrichment prior to joining
kindan he was a postdoctoral fellow at
the National Cancer Institute conducting
research in the field of cancer
immunology with emphasis on identifying
strategies to boost the efficacy of
cancer vaccines you received his PhD
from Georgetown University in tumor
biology I will now turn over to read for
his presentation thank you soon and
thank you everyone for joining this
webinar as a starting point I just want
to go over a a brief agenda first I will
go over a liquid biopsies for precision
medicine how they can be used to drive
the idea of precision medicine second
I'll address the the some of the
challenges associated with liquid
biopsies and then third show you how
liquid biopsies can be used especially
in in the NGS field for biomarker
discovery and then close this off with a
summary and questions so first on to
liquid biopsies for precision medicine
so the idea of precision medicine is to
deliver the right drug for the right
patient at the right time and at the
right dose what you see on this on this
screen and let me just get this ongoing
here on the on the left you see this
sort of one-size-fits-all approach which
has been the traditional approach for
developing drugs and delivering them to
to patients we know that the
one-size-fits-all approach does not work
anymore this is because a specific
therapy can have three kinds of effects
you can have a positive effect you can
have a no effect and you can have an
adverse effect now what we're what we're
doing right now is to use genomic
information to deliver precision
medicine with precision medicine we are
using the information that's based in
someone's in someone's genome to deliver
a specific therapy that will only have a
positive effect hopefully and and avoid
all the no effects or adverse effects
so in order to do so we need to look for
for specific DNA variants that are
present in in one's genome and the idea
of looking at DNA variants is is shown
on this slide over here what I'm showing
you here is just three types of DNA
variants that one can look at first the
most popular types of DNA variants are
DNA mutations with DNA mutations you
have a specific change in a nucleotide
that can either result in this in indy
in the as an example in cancer that can
result in the over activation of a
specific oncogene or the suppression of
a tumor suppressor gene which will drive
the development and progression of
cancer in Delta is another form of DNA
variants in they'll stand for insertions
and deletions with with insertions and
deletions you have specific segments of
the genome where where you see certain
nucleotides being inserted in in the
coding regions of specific genes and
with the with the case of deletions you
have specific nucleotides that are being
deleted from certain regions of the gene
and again these will result in changes
in the activity of that of that protein
leading to the development of diseases
another form of DNA variants that we see
is copy number variations where you see
a you know a specific gene being copied
over and over and what you end up with
is several copies of that gene leading
to the overexpression of that specific
of that specific gene now why is this
important this is important because we
know we can target these DNA variants
for precision medicine or to deliver the
idea of precision medicine however we
know that there are only a handful of
mutations that are actionable and what I
when I say actionable it's the it's the
idea that we can actually target those
DNA variants with either specific
therapies or use that information for
disease management just as examples I
mentioned three types of variants
mutations insertions and deletions and
copy number variants and what I'm
showing you here are examples of how
these specific variants can be targeted
now these specific variants are
detrimental to to to to to someone's
health be
they drive the development and
progression of diseases specifically
cancer but the good news is that we can
use that information and target those
specific DNA variants and deliver on
deliver therapies or medications that
can actually make a difference in terms
of precision medicine so in terms of as
an example of a specific mutation that
we can target I'm highlighting the DRS
v600e mutation this is the mutation that
is seen heavily in in melanoma cases but
the good news is that we can target the
specific mutation with a specific
therapy called them raffinate then we
raffinate is a tyrosine kinase inhibitor
that specifically specifically targets
the bureau's v600e mutation when we look
at in dells we know that there are
certain deletions within the egfr gene
and changes within the kinase domain
that are heavily seen in lung
adenocarcinomas and the good news is
that these types of variants can be
targeted with another class of tyrosine
kinase inhibitors such as erlotinib or
just sit in it on the copy number
variants side we know that the
amplification of her to is heavily seen
in breast cancer cases and these types
of variants can be targeted with a drug
called trastuzumab which which targets
the the overexpression of her to on in
such cases so again while these types of
variants are detrimental because they
drive the the development and
progression of specific diseases we can
actually use now those DNA variants to
deliver therapies that are tailored to
the genomic composition of that disease
so what types of variants can we target
and in how many variants or actionable
variants exist out there so I'm in the
previous slide I mentioned that the
number of variants is limited or
actionable variants is limited and this
is actually shown over here so what I'm
showing you is sort of a filter
filtering process by which all these
different variants and common variants
that we see in individuals get filtered
down to the biologically relevant and
actionable variants so we start off
anyone who has run an NG
experiment can appreciate the number of
variants that you that one would see in
a sample so you go from all these common
variants that you see in a sample and
after going through this filtering
cascade or filtering process where you
remove variants that have no obvious
effect on protein and you go through
this iterative biological interpretation
to make sure that you've interpreted the
what's what those with those variants
mean from a biological and clinical
standpoint you end up with only tens of
biologically relevant actionable
variants so these are the variants that
we can actually target with specific
therapies or variants that can be useful
for for determining you know what what
has been driving that disease in and
where that disease is going so you start
off with millions of common variants
especially if you're looking at you know
hundreds of genes or if you're looking
at the entire genome you have millions
of common variants that get filtered
down to tens of biologically relevant
and actionable variants so just as an
example I'm using some data that they've
adapted from a paper published in cell
back in 2012 and it was it was a paper
that looked at the lung cancer biomarker
landscape what the authors wanted to do
here is to understand the types of
variants that accumulate in in one
cancer specimen and when they look at
the types of mutations and the
percentage of these mutations on they do
see that twenty-five percent of cases
accumulate mutations in the chaos gene
we have twenty three percent of the
mutations accumulating twenty three
percent of cases accumulating mutations
in the egfr gene and then you have the
smaller number of cases that accumulates
a smaller number of variants in
different genes such as BRS met pi3
kinase and so on and so forth now why is
this important in from this information
is important it's important for a couple
of reasons first to understand the
underlying mechanisms of what is driving
lung cancer but it's also important from
a from a therapeutic perspective we know
for instance that those cases that have
the l85 8r EGFR mutation they respond
very well to a class of
of tyrosine kinase inhibitors that I
mentioned earlier or LA tenebra fit in
it however if you have the same cases
presenting with with another type of
mutation in the chaos gene the g12 see
mutation we know that those responses
now dropped so having that one mutation
is very favorable because we know we can
target the specific mutation with a
class of drugs but if we see this
another type of mutation in the K rest
kay rasa gene these responses now
dropped so again this information is
important to understand what is
happening at the molecular molecular
level but it's also important because
now we can target those types of
mutations with specific drugs now the
question always comes up is how do you
test for these mutations do you do
sequential testing which means you test
first 4k rafts mutations and then second
egfr mutations and then b-raf mutations
and so on and so forth or do you test
them in parallel which means that you're
testing all of these mutations in the
same assay now the the answer is going
to depend on on the type of technology
that you have in your lab and and and
also the the amount of sample that
you're working with sequential testing
using individual let's say let's call
them pcr assays gives you a very high
degree of accuracy but it's going to
take a lot of time think of all the time
that is needed and required to run these
individual assays and also the the
sample might be very limiting especially
if you're using liquid biopsies which I
will get into get get into in a bit you
might not have a whole lot of DNA to
work with so sequential testing is going
to take a lot of time and it's going to
take I'll take up a lot of material
parallel testing using next-generation
sequencing allows you to look at all of
these different mutations in just one
assay so you're you're decreasing the
amount of time required to look at all
of these mutations and you're also
dropping down the DVD na requirements
for to look at all of these mutations so
again instead of using you know hundreds
of nano grams or micrograms of DNA to
look at all of these mutations
sequentially you can drop this down to
maybe 10 nano grams if you if you're
used
a-and NGSS a and look at all of these
mutations in parallel the idea of using
liquid biopsy for precision medicine has
been shown for a while now this is a
paper one of the earliest papers that I
could come across that actually looked
at how to use liquid biopsies for
precision medicine was a paper published
back in 2012 and Science Translational
Medicine and basically they showed that
liquid biopsies can be used to screen
for and identify low frequency mutations
so you can actually look at mutations
that are present as well as two percent
in your sample which is which is
extremely important because you want to
be able to capture these these mutations
that are present at low frequencies they
showed that liquid biopsy can be used to
non-invasively identify the origin of
metastatic relapse in a patient with
multiple primary tumors and they were
able to show that they can use the idea
of liquid biopsy for precision medicine
to monitor tumor dynamics by tracking
ten different mutations in plasma
automatic static breast cancer patient
over 16 months so you can actually now
use you have an easier way of monitoring
the you know disease dynamics and
disease progression traditionally we had
to go and obtain solid solid biopsies
which is prohibitive because you cannot
bring in the same individual and just
biopsy them over and over but with
liquid biopsies with just a draw blood
now you can actually track this this
this disease and monitor it over time so
how do you examine variants by next
generation sequencing I personally
believe that next generation sequencing
is the ideal approach if you want to
look at multiple mutations using the
same sample in the same assay but how do
you examine variance by next-generation
sequencing there are three levels that I
can think of one is whole genome
sequencing and then second is whole
exome sequencing as you can see on this
slide and then you have targeted DNA
sequencing the difference between these
three levels is like looking at a force
so with a whole genome sequencing
approach what you're doing is you're
basically if there's high level overview
of what is what is going on in that
sample and in
and in examining their genetic variants
with a whole exome sequencing approach
instead of instead of just looking at
the trees from top now you're starting
to see those the trunks of the trees so
you're taking a deeper view into into
that sample and into these variants with
the targeted DNA sequencing approach now
you're seeing the fine details of these
trunks so again we've taken this sort of
this tiered approach going from a very
high level overview all the way to
looking at the details of these of the
trunks of those trees and what I've done
here is I've summarized the differences
between those three approaches on many
attributes information level cost per
sample and the ability to detect
low-frequency mutations at the
information level we're looking at
everything when we look at a whole
genome sequencing approach we're looking
at every single base the 3 billion bases
that are present in one genome with a
whole exome sequencing approach we're
looking only at the coding regions of
genes so we're looking at you know
20,000 genes this this might be maybe 60
million bases or so for for the whole
whole exome sequencing approach with a
targeted DNA sequencing approach this is
user defined you as a user and
researcher you're going to define the
regions of the genome that you want to
look at this could be you know specific
hot spots within within within oncogenes
or looking at you know the entire coding
regions of tumor suppressor genes these
could be maybe ten tumor suppressor
genes or you can be looking at a
collection of 50 genes all in all so
this is a user-defined you as the
researcher you're defining the regions
that you want to look at so in terms of
information level this can be down to
you know a thousand bases up to maybe
one mega base or so of the genome cost
per sample is going to differ we all are
striving to that whole genome sequencing
approach of a thousand dollars per
sample but we we know we're not there
yet so if we just look at an average of
how much it would cost to take a whole
genome sequencing approach right now
it's about five thousand dollars or even
more depending on depending on you know
the approach that you take and depending
on the on the provider that you use if
you're if you're outsourcing this to to
a third-party vent vendor but it still
sits around five thousand dollars which
is expensive if you're doing a lot of a
lot of samples looking at a whole exome
sequencing approach you might be paying
about two thousand dollars or so per
sample so which is which is still
expensive again if you're looking at
multiple samples with a targeted DNA
sequencing approach you can drop this
down to maybe two hundred dollars or so
depending on your multiplexing level
level on a sequence or end the sequencer
that you're using but so it is more
cost-effective to do a targeted DNA
sequencing approach detection of
low-frequency mutations this is going to
depend on your on your depth of coverage
we know with a whole genome sequencing
approach you cannot detect those
low-frequency mutations because you're
not getting the depth of coverage that
is required to look at these at these
types of mutations whole exome
sequencing approach maybe you can get
this up to maybe a hundred x or even a
little bit a little bit more than that
but that's still not enough to look at
those low frequency mutations with a
targeted DNA sequencing approach because
your your your region of interest is
much smaller than a whole exome or whole
genome you can actually increase the
depth of coverage per sample and and be
able to look at these low frequency
mutations now looking at DNA input and
number of samples multiplex they are
these three approaches also differ on
these two parameters for DNA input we
know we need a lot of DNA in order to do
this whole genome sequencing approach
you need at least one microgram of DNA
in order to look at every single base
and again for specific samples such as
liquid biopsies this is going to be very
limiting you might not get one microgram
of DNA from your sample with a whole
sequencing whole exome sequencing
approach you can drop this down to maybe
a hundred to two hundred nano grams
which again could be limiting if you're
looking at liquid biopsies but for a
targeted DNA sequencing approach you're
looking at 10 nano grams only so so in
order to look at these multiple
mutations from a liquid biopsy using the
targeted DNA sequencing approach you
would or you would only need 10
milligrams or so which is now very
for for those liquid biopsies numbers of
samples or number of samples multiplexed
this refers to the number of samples
that you can sequence in the same
sequencing run with a whole genome and
whole exome approach we're still not
capable of multiplexing many samples so
you can go between you know one to two
samples or so for for these types of
approaches which is why you still have
the cost per sample very high but for a
targeted DNA sequencing approach you can
go up to 96 samples or even higher / /
sequencing runs so you're basically
splitting all the costs of a sequencing
run over 96 samples and that's why the
cost per sample is going to decrease so
there are several advantages to each one
of these approaches there is no right or
wrong approach the right approach is
just going to depend on the type of
question that you are asking and what
types of of resources you have but if we
look at the benefits of targeted DNA
sequencing it gives you more relevant
data because you as a researcher you are
defining this those regions that you
want to look at it is more cost
effective as the cost per sample drops
down it gives you the ability to detect
low-frequency mutations as opposed to
whole genome and whole exome sequencing
approaches it has a lower DNA
requirement so that it allows you now to
take advantage of liquid biopsies to
examine all these DNA variants that are
important for for the disease that
you're studying and the number of
samples multiplexed goes up so it gives
you this higher multiplexing
capabilities which speeds up your
process and also drops down the cost per
sample but again the the there is no
right or wrong approach it's just the
approach is going to depend on the
question that you are asking and the
resources that you have so why choose
targeted DNA sequencing again it gives a
well-defined content so you are looking
at those regions that are important to
what you are doing it offers you a small
target size so you can multiplex many
samples to save money and it gives you
more reads per sample so you can detect
those low-frequency variants again the
more the larger size you're looking at
of the genome the the lower the number
of samples that can
multiplex so if you're looking at a
smaller region within the genome you can
actually multiplex many samples in the
same sequencing run which which which
drives down the cost but it also gives
you more reads per sample or more
sequencing budget per sample so you can
actually now look at these low frequency
variants so just to kind of put this
into a visual over here so once once the
DNA is isolated and what you're looking
at here is just a generic approach to
targeted DNA sequencing it all starts
with sample isolation so think of all
that DNA that you've isolated from your
from your sample because it is a
targeted DNA sequencing approach you
have this targeted enrichment step
that's where you're enriching for for
all the the different regions of the
genome that you want to look at and just
just for simplicity I'm only
highlighting three genes here that are
heavily implicated in different cancers
ke RS EGFR and idh1 so the idea is to
shrink that the genome that you've that
you've isolated from your sample down to
those three genes you can do so in many
different ways you can do so by pcr
bye-bye just generating amplicons that
represent those jeans or you can do this
by a hybridization based approach by
pulling down those regions of interest
so following following the targeted
enrichment step you're going to
construct your libraries you're going to
see those libraries to make sure you
have enough enough of them and of the
right quality you're going to then
sequence the libraries that you've
constructed and then send that the data
that has been generated into that
analysis and interpretation and the idea
again behind targeted DNA sequencing is
that when you what you end up with is
just information on those genes that
you've enriched for because these are
the genes that you are interested in and
these are the genes that are relevant to
that disease that you are studying so so
again instead of looking at every single
base what you end up with at that
interpretation step is you're looking at
variants that are present in the chaos
gene in the egfr gene and idh1 gene so
you are not reporting on all of the
variants that are present in the genome
instead you're only looking at the
variants that are present in those three
cheese's
so what are the challenges now of used a
liquid biopsy approach in NGS to look at
all these different variants liquid
biopsy approaches as as great and and
promising as they are they found and
they are but there are a lot of
challenges mainly you have low DNA
quality so the DNA that you get from
from liquid biopsies are highly
fragmented and because it because this
DNA is highly fragmented this is going
to limit your capabilities to use them
to use that DNA in NGS or other assays
you also have low DNA quantity so the
quantities that you get are not going to
be enough to allow you to maybe look at
a whole genome approach or a whole exome
approach you get low nanogram ranges of
DNA from these types of biopsies and
again because they will they will limit
your capability to one or so of the
different NGS approaches another
challenge is the ability to detect those
low frequency those low variant allele
frequency mutations they are they could
be present at 125 percent of the sample
and you need a a specific approach that
allows you to actually look at these low
frequency mutations in in liquid
biopsies so these are the three main
challenges that we see with liquid
biopsies and what I will do in the next
part of this presentation is to show you
you know how you can address these types
of challenges using using some of our
approaches so first on to low DNA
quality again we know that the quality
is not is not as good when when you look
at DNA isolated from from liquid
biopsies and so you need to choose a
approach that allows you to enrich your
targets very efficiently from these from
these highly damaged DNA DNA samples as
I mentioned earlier there are two ways
to enrich for your targets you can do a
you can take a multiplex PCR based
approach or you can do a hybridization
based approach to different approaches
each one has its advantages and
disadvantages this was actually not very
nicely highlighted and in this paper
published in Nature
back in 2010 where they actually
compared those two to enrichment
methodologies head-to-head and their
their conclusion is that the specificity
of PCR and the uniformity of PCR will be
will be pretty much unmatched so but
then but the the appropriate approach is
is going to depend also on how large of
a target size you're looking at so again
there is no right or wrong approach it
depends on how many bases are you are
you enriching in your sample if you have
a very large region that you want to
enrich something that's more than one
mega base or 1 million bases the
hybridization based approach tends to be
more efficient because it's more
efficient than capturing these these
reasons but if you have a smaller target
region something that is smaller than 1
million bases the specificity and
uniformity that you get with a multiplex
PCR based approach is basically
unmatched PCR we know PCR gives us the
highly specific type of setup and highly
highly uniform type of setup for
enriching those regions so if you have a
smaller region multiplex PCR tends to be
more more specific and more uniform and
that is the reason why we chose at tizen
we chose to go with a multiplex PCR
based approach because the idea of using
targeted DNA sequencing you're you're
really not interested in looking at
anything more than 1 million bases or so
1 million bases just to kind of give you
a idea or to try to translate that into
a number of genes 1 million bases can
can be translated to about 200 200 genes
or so um which is quite a bit for for a
targeted DNA sequencing approach we
usually look at you know maybe 1550
genes or 50 to 100 genes so 1 million
bases is more than enough for for
targeted DNA sequencing approaches and
that's why we chose the multiplex PCR
based approach because it gives us this
high degree of specificity nearly
formula so the idea behind a multiplex
PCR based approach is very simple we
look at
as an example we're only looking here at
two genes gene 1 and gene too let's call
those jeans these are the genes that I
am interested in for for the disease
that I'm studying with a multiplex pcr
based approach what we do the very first
step is to is to design primers that
correspond to those to those two genes
so I'm showing you here for support if
you just the call that's just one x on
of gene one and one taxon of gene to you
see all the different primers that are
being designed that covered the gene one
or gene two after we designed those
primers we run them through a specific
algorithm to separate those primers we
separate them in a way to keep the
amplicons generated very small remember
the the DNA that you get from liquid
biopsies are heavily is heavily damaged
so the smaller the amplicons the more
efficient they work with damaged DNA so
we separate those primers in a way to
keep the house becomes very small so for
instance this pair the pair that is
shown in let me see if I can get this
guy over here so so basically we have
this this primer pair being separated in
one in one PC our pool and then this
primer pair being separated in another
pcr pool this primer pair being may be
separated in another in a third pcr pool
and so on and so forth the maximum
number of pools would be four but we
basically separate those all those
primers into individual pcr pools for a
total and a maximum number of for this
can be one two three or four pcr pools
but that is the idea of a multiplex pcr
we define the region's first we we use a
primary design algorithm to design
primers that correspond to these genes
and will allow us to enrich them in a
simple mode simple pcr set up and then
we use another algorithm to separate
those those primers in an appropriate
number of PCR pools and that is what
would I mean by a panel so when I talk
about a panel for targeted DNA
sequencing for liquid biopsy approaches
I'm talking about the collection of all
these primers that have been separated
into an appropriate number of PCR pools
and of course the corresponding
pcr chemistry that goes with it so when
again when i talk about and a multiplex
pcr based approach for targeted
enrichment i'm talking about the panel
itself which is a collection of all
those primers as well as the pcr
chemistry that goes with it we've
developed the gene read DNA seek
Connells version 2 44 targeted
enrichment so these are all the primers
that correspond again to those regions
that I want to enrich and we've
developed a gene read DNA CTC our kit
version to that that goes with the panel
um it's basically pcr chemistry to allow
us to use those primers and enrich for
for those jeans that were interested in
again going back to the to the previous
example that would be gene one and gene
too so so going back to the idea of or
the challenges of obvious if I ups the
approaches i mentioned that the DNA that
you get from liquid biopsies is heavily
damaged so you you really need to use
small amplicons in order to efficiently
enrich for your for your regions of
interest from this heavily damaged DNA
the amplicon size that we use is a
hundred and fifty basis which is which
is small enough to work with damaged DNA
it still gives us enough information to
be accurately to be to be able to
accurately map those the reads that are
coming off these amplicons very
efficiently to the to the reference
genome so 150 base pair amplicons again
because of the the nature of that DNA
that is heavily damaged we want to keep
those amplicons as small as possible so
so we designed the primers and separate
them in a way to generate 150 based or
applicants now looking at DNA quantity
again I mentioned that you don't get a
whole lot of DNA from liquid biopsy from
the liquid biopsy approach your you'll
be lucky if you get you know enough DNA
and in the low nanogram range from from
from these types of samples and in in
order to to to to be able to do targeted
DNA sequencing you need a system that
requires very minimal inputs of DNA with
the gene read
workflow that we have put together you
only need 10 milligrams per pcr pool
which basically means 10 milligrams of
of DNA in each pcr poor as i mentioned
earlier the panels are split or the
primers in a panel are split into an
appropriate number of pcr pools this can
range between one and four and so for
each one of these pcr pools you need you
need 10 milligrams of DNA now if we go
back to the amount of DNA that one gets
from liquid biopsies this is this is
sort of a sweet spot because it actually
it uses enough DNA to get to be able to
enrich for your targets and actually
still might gives you it might allow you
to use to use that same sample for
additional tests if we look at the
amount of DNA that one gets from from
liquid biopsies again this is going to
range but but you can easily get about
20 nano grams of of DNA from your from
from a liquid biopsy and if if the if
the biopsy comes from a you know a very
advanced disease individual you actually
might get up to 40 nano grams or even 15
anagrams of DNA and if you're using you
know a a panel of one or two pools this
is definitely enough the DNA that you've
isolated is definitely enough to run
this this panel for targeted DNA
sequencing so again we've kept the mint
the DNA requirements to to a minimum it
is ten anagrams for pcr pool which is
enough to run a targeted DNA sequencing
approach on liquid biopsies so what do
we do for those low frequency mutations
again especially especially for cancer
for cancer studies and cancer samples it
is important to be able to to detect
those low frequency mutations because of
tumor heterogeneity we know that you
know tumors tumors will shed different
types of different amounts of DNA that
contain very low frequency mutations
because of tumor heterogeneity so we
need a system that allows us to to be
able to detect those low frequency
mutation
and what we've done to tackle this
problem is is to use different types of
amplicon designs so we've developed
different types of panels as I will show
you in a bit and each panel utilizes a
specific amplicon design that is a that
is appropriate for the applicant that
specific application to which that panel
was developed so just to give you an
example we have this cancer actionable
mutations panel which is the which is a
hotspot panel that we have developed
specifically for those types of DNA
variants that are present at very low
frequencies if you look at the design of
amplicons in this cancer actionable
mutations panel you do see that specific
low site within the genome are covered
by multiple different amplicons so as an
example i'm showing you here the region
of krad g12 so this is a region of the
KS gene that is heavily mutated and and
those mutations are seen across a wide
range of different cancers because it is
such an important locus in within the
genome what we've done with this cancer
actionable mutations panel is to design
multiple different amplicons that span
this specific locus of the KSG you see
four different amplicons over here
covering this specific locus what this
does is that it gives us a higher degree
of coverage across that specific locus
and it also ensures against any dropouts
within within those with within that
region so if for whatever reason one of
those applicants drops out we know that
we have three other amplicons covering
that specific locus and so what we end
up with is is a sort of will definitely
be able to read this specific locus with
this actionable mutations panel again
we've developed this panel as a hotspot
panel and we wanted to ensure that all
these hot spots are being read in the in
the NGSS a and that's why you see this
deep or redundant tiling amplicon
approach we have four different
amplicons covering that specific locus
now if you look at other panels like the
clinically relevant panel which is an
extended version of the actionable
mutations panel you don't really see we
don't see this sort of deep redundant
tiling the
the region of the genome has increased
and by increasing the region of the
genome we had to do we have to drop the
number of amplicons but you still see
this sort of dense overlap of amplicons
covering these specific hotspots so for
instance again that g12 locus of KS is
still covered by two amplicons again to
ensure that this this specific locus is
being read by this by this assay so
different different designs for
different applications but but again in
order to tackle the idea of this of the
low-frequency mutations that you see
within liquid biopsies we wanted to make
sure that we we have this redundant
coverage across these these these low
side that are important for for cancer
applications another another approach
that we have taken to to look at these
low frequency mutations within liquid
biopsies is is to actually not digest
off the not to digest off the the primer
sequences within the reins so so one
thing that you really need to do in an
applicant sequencing is to trim off the
primer sequences from your read so
you're not calling any variance within
those primer sequences but when you
digest those off or when you remove
those those those primer sequences going
to make and a big difference in your
ability to call these low frequency
mutations if you digest those those
primer sequences physically before you
do the before you do the mapping and an
alignment steps what you end up with is
is missing some of the variants around
the ends of the amplicons in order to
circumvent this what we have done is we
take the primer sequences all throughout
the day sequencing process up to the
point of variant calling and right
before variant calling we remove those
bio informatica remove the primer
sequences so we're using all of this
information all the primer sequences to
protect the ends of amplicons and then
we're using that information 24 hour
alignment steps this gives us more
information and more more sort of
nucleotides to to accurately mapped the
the reads to the reference genome but
then right after the mapping and
alignment steps we trim off those primer
sequences so we are not calling any
variance within those primer sequences
are external sequences and you do not
want to call any variance within those
sequences but so what this does is that
it allows us to protect the ends of
amplicons and allows us to increase the
ability to call variants within the ends
of the amplicons and this is actually
nicely shown in a paper that was
published last year that compared our
our workflow that does not digest off
the these sequences of of those climbers
versus another workflow that uses
multiplex PCR that physically digest the
the primer sequences you know before the
sequencing reaction and when they
compared the two workflows and their
ability to call mutations you know they
basically looked at sensitivity and
specificity what they show in their
paper is is that the the d'occasion
workflow was able to look at or detect a
hundred percent of of all those
mutations that are present in their
samples so basically 77 out of 77
mutations were called using that
workflow however looking at a different
workflow that that again uses multiplex
PCR based approach that digests the
primer sequences before the sequencing
reaction they show that five mutations
were not called using that workflow and
it happened that those mutations were at
the amplicon boundaries and primer
binding sites again because that up
because that workflow digests off the
primer sequences you're losing the
capability to call mutations at the ends
of amplicons and that's why you see that
there are five mutations that were
missing from used by using that workflow
compared to the workflow that we have
put together so again keeping those
primer sequences and only removing them
before the variant calling step is an
extremely important aspect of this
approach
tickly for liquid biopsy approaches
again remember you don't have a whole
lot of DNA and you want to look at these
low frequency mutations so so I
mentioned that the we've developed
several types of panels and the panels
that we have developed our platform
independent so it gives you this this
added level of flexibility a lot of
customers do have access to two
different to different instruments and
in some you know some researchers used
two different instruments in order to
confirm the presence of variance with
our approach you don't have to to buy a
new a new panel because you're using a
different sequencer you can use the same
panel on different sequencers whether
you're using sequencers from you know
from the alumina platforms or the Ion
Torrent platforms you can use the same
panel and only the the part of the
workflow that is sequence are specific
is the the library preparation step
which is which follows the targeted
enrichment step what types of panels
have we developed again I mentioned
we've developed a number of panels for
different applications going from solid
tumors to hematologic malignancies to
tissue specific content even gene
specific content and comprehensive
content I mentioned the actionable
mutations now this is the hot spot panel
that we have developed but for solid
tumors you also can use the clinically
relevant tumor panel which is an
extended version of the actionable
mutations panel for hematologic
malignancy there's a Mylo do Platinum's
panel tissue-specific panels you know
they we've developed content for
different types of cancers from breast
cancer to colorectal cancer liver cancer
and so on and so forth and even one for
cardiomyopathy content the bracket one
bracket to panel is our example of a
gene-specific panel this is a panel that
enriches for all the exonic regions or
Braca one and bracket 2 and then for the
comprehensive contest content we have
the cancer predisposition panel the
carrier testing panel and the
comprehensive cancer panel so really
different types of of panels for
different applications if you want
something that is
very small that allows you to reach that
high level of depth of coverage and
allows you to multiplex many samples
together you have you have access to
those smaller panels of the actionable
mutations and clinically relevant if you
want something that is more
comprehensive that allows you to look at
you know 160 genes or so you can you
have access me to the comprehensive
cancer panel but because this is a large
panel your multiplexing capabilities of
course decrease and the the depth of
coverage also decreases unless you use
you know a high seek or one of those
more more powerful more powerful
sequencers but again you have we've
developed different types of content
different types of sizes to to to fit
different types of applications if you
have your own content you can also build
your own your own panel through the
mix-and-match collection this gives you
access to 570 bench tested gene designs
or if you do not find your your genes of
interest within the mix-and-match
collection you can go through the custom
offering you can define your own regions
you can define your own genes and build
build a panel that said that
specifically fits your your own
requirements the turnaround time for
both of them is pretty quick with the
mix and match you can from from from the
time that that order is submitted we
turn this around in three days and for
the custom panel it's about 14 days or
two weeks but really all you need is
that list of targets that that you're
interested in so to give you an example
of the power of mix and match because
these are genes that we've already
tested the the performance of these gene
designs is pretty consistent across
different panels so as an example here
I'm highlighting the design of the met
gene in four different or five different
panels you see that the specificity and
uniformity of of the coverage from that
from that gene design is pretty
consistent across all the different
panels we know that one one gene design
is going to behave differently if you
put that gene design with with you know
ten other genes or 20 other genes but
because these gene designs have been
previously tested and optimized we know
that the gene designs are differ
delivering pretty consistent performance
across different panels so the what are
the benefits i think i've talked about
all the different benefits for for for
the approach that we have put together
from you know multiplexing many samples
simultaneously to achieving a higher
specificity and uniformity to just to
the ability of sequencing low quality
samples so another another unique aspect
of the workflow that we have put
together is that analysis and
interpretation so the amount of
information that you generate is is huge
you need a system that allows you to
efficiently analyze the data and also
interpret it and for that we have a
strong pipeline of products that I will
not go through today before for the sake
of time there's the CLC by offering
these are these are pipelines that allow
you to you know to call variants so you
take all the the fast Q files or bad
files that have been generated from the
by the sequencer you run them through
the CLC bio pipelines and in what you
end up with is a list of all the
different variants that have been
detected in your samples it's a very
flexible tool you build your own
pipeline but you don't really need to be
a expert in bioinformatics this actually
has it was built for for also those that
do not have any bio informatics
expertise you start building this
pipeline by putting together these these
boxes and these boxes are
self-explanatory they actually tell you
what this box means and what it does so
you can start building this your own
pipeline and what is neat about about
the CLC bio platform also that there is
a plug-in for the GRE DNA see taare
gated panels so the pipeline for
analyzing amplicons coming out of those
panels has already been built into the
CLC bio pipelines all you have to do is
just double click on that plug-in and it
actually build this pipeline for you so
you don't have to go back and basically
reinvent the wheel all that pipeline has
been already has been developed for you
you can lock this this system if you do
not want to any want to change the
settings we know that changing one
setting can can make
huge difference in that analysis and so
you have the flexibility of locking this
system where you have the flex or the
option of keeping it open but you can
define your own parameters and
thresholds for for that analysis that's
one of the beauties of the system is
that it's not a black box it's actually
you can turn it into a black box if you
want to but you you as a user you can
change the settings the way you need so
once the variants have been identified
by the CLC bio platform you can actually
use the the ingenuity variant analysis
platforms for the interpretation part so
so one thing is to call variants another
thing is to make sense of those variants
what does it mean to see a bracket to
mutation in your samples from a
biological and clinical standpoint what
does it mean to see this this new EGFR
mutation that no one has seen before in
your samples the ingenuity variant
analysis platforms allow you to take
that that interpretation step it shows
you all the different variants that have
been detected you can go through this
filtering cascade that I mentioned
previously whereby you're removing a lot
of common variants you're removing
variants that are not confident Lee
called and so on and so forth and this
tool also links all the different
variants to to what is known already
about these variants in the literature
if there are papers that that exists
that have described a specific variant
you can double-click on those papers in
in read about that specific variant to
kind of give you more more information
about about all those variants that have
been detected in your samples so so just
to kind of summarize what I've said so
far and I think the next the next topic
on the agenda is just to give you an
example and and I'll show you that in a
bit but but we really see the way we see
the different panels being used for
targeted DNA sequencing is depends on
the application you know if you're
interested in a lot of detection
capabilities you generally start using
those smaller panels like the actionable
mutations and clinically relevant panels
as you move to the right of this slide
you know the target size increases
because you're interested more in
discovery and you know as you go to the
very far right of this of this of
slide you know you see whole exome and
whole genome being used and this goes
back to to the point I made previously
there's no one right or wrong approach
it all depends on what you're trying to
do if you want the ability to detect
low-frequency mutations you want a
smaller panel if you want the ability to
discover new mutations you want
something that is more comprehensive
like the whole exome or whole genome
approach you can use panels to to
discover to discover novel mutations
this was nicely shown in a paper
published in Nature Genetics back in
2014 a lot of papers after that have
shown the ability to use panels to to
discover new mutations but again
remember that discovery is going to be
limited because you are looking at a
limited number of genes but you can
still use a small panel to to to
discover new new mutations within those
jeans so how can you use liquid biopsies
for precision medicine I'm going to use
an example from from the literature it
was a paper that was recently published
on the landscape of resistance mutations
in non-small cell lung cancer so we know
that EGF for mutant lung cancer is a
subtype of non-small non-small cell lung
cancer that exhibits sensitivity to egfr
tyrosine kinase inhibitors so again
these types of there are certain
mutations that make these these types of
cancers sensitive to these tyrosine
kinase inhibitors however we know that
acquired resistance develops after a
median of 9 to 14 months so with with
this paper that I want to to talk about
the the authors wanted to answer this
question of can we can we start looking
at these resistance mutations well
before that resistance actually develops
in these types of cancers and we know
that the most common mechanism of
resistance is a second site mutation in
egfr t790m mutation when as this
mutation actually mediates resistance to
these tyrosine kinase inhibitors so what
the authors of this paper wanted to do
they basically wanted to answer this
question of can we identify potential
mechanisms of resistance to a tyrosine
kinase inhibitors
has been developed to specifically
target the t790m mutation before the
availability of a resistance biopsy
specimen so can we use blood samples
basically to predict what is going to
happen to those individuals who are
treated with this tyrosine kinase
inhibitor the azd 929 one that has been
developed to overcome the t790m mutation
and so what they what they what they've
done is they used one of our panels to
screen cell free DNA plasma basically
you know they took a liquid biopsy
approach to look at a patient samples in
a phase 1 clinical trial and again they
wanted to identify those those
mechanisms of resistance this was nicely
described in a paper published last year
in May of 2015 in nature medicine and
basically what they their approach was a
liquid biopsy approach right so they
what they did is they collected plasma
they prepared the the plasma from or
they collected blood samples they
prepared plasma from these blood samples
they isolated cell-free DNA using the
kaya amp circulating nucleic acid kit
they then they use this DNA in an
enrichment step they enrich 20 genes
using the gene read dna-seq on cancer
panel they constructed libraries for a
loop for Illumina platforms and they
used the high seek to do to get this
ultra deep sequencing they were
achieving 30,000 x across the you know
the regions of interest which is very
very very high but you'll see why this
is important because they were looking
at mutations that are present at around
one percent or so so when they as a
proof of concept they just looked at DNA
isolated from from plasma of of baseline
conditions and progression conditions so
progression that's where we that's when
the disease progressed and basically
what they wanted to do again they wanted
to see if they can identify novel
mutations that can mediate resistance to
that second class tyrosine kinase
inhibitor so you still see this t790m
mutation across baseline on progression
that's expected because because these
patients already has t790m mutations now
however what they started seeing is this
novel this new mutation the sea
the sea 797 s mutation that is being
developed in under progression
conditions that they have not seen at
baseline so just as a proof of concept
in this one sample they just wanted to
see if they can detect these novel
mutations in in liquid biopsies as a way
to to predict what's going to happen in
terms of resistance then they extended
this to too many more samples and they
started also comparing what they see in
the plasma to what they see in the tumor
so you're looking at here it's just just
you know one one example where they
looked at mutations in the plasma
samples and the tumor samples under
baseline and progression conditions and
what they show here is that again you
see the t790m mutation because again the
this population was enriched for for
this for this type of mutation but then
when they started looking at the sea 797
c79 so then s locust in in egfr they
started seeing this mutation develop
under progression conditions that is
absent from the baseline condition so
you see that the there is ninety percent
of the mutations seen within within this
this sample belong to the sea 797 s
mutation in the tumor and they also see
this in the plasma so so they're they're
not seeing the same exact type of you
know numbers but but you still see this
type of mutation both in the tumor and
the plasma and you see see two different
genotypes for this for the specific for
the same mutation you have a t2 a change
and you have a g2c change also so
basically what this is telling us is
that first you can use the liquid biopsy
approach to to monitor disease
progression and resistance and you can
start actually predicting what's going
to happen to those tumors after they've
been treated with the second class
tyrosine kinase inhibitor so to close
this off with a summary targeted DNA
sequencing enables precision medicine
using liquid biopsies again the paper
that that i discussed nicely shows how
you can use liquid biopsy approaches for
for precision medicine targeted DNA
sequencing can be used to detect these
low frequency mutations it's important
to if you're looking at cancer it's
important to look at these low frequency
mutations because a lot of cancer cases
have these low frequency mutations that
can drive disease progression
development and progression amplicon
based enrichment using multiplex pcr
delivers the high level of specificity
and uniformity that are required to
overcome the low quality and quantity of
liquid biopsy DNA and also redundant and
overlapping amplicon designs deliver the
deep coverage that is required for the
detection of those low-frequency
mutations and liquid biopsies are an
efficient way to monitor disease
progression and resistance in
specifically again in cancer
applications so that's all I have for
today I want to thank you all for for
your for your attendance and your time
and I believe soon it's time for
questions yeah that was an excellent
presentation and thank you for being
that information to us is really
fantastic before we get started with all
of your questions here's a quick
reminder about how to reach us today
questions can be sent via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window and we'll get to as
many questions as we can right the first
question for you is the sequencing from
DNA sequencing DNA from exosomes work in
the same way at CF DNA yeah i mean the
principle is pretty much the same the
type of information might that you that
you get might be different because they
come from different compartment but you
know as long as you can isolate DNA from
exosomes you know of good quality and
enough quantity you should be able to
use targeted DNA sequencing for using
exosomes fantastic your next question
nani member wants to know how different
is this approach and then capture based
methods for enrichment and which
approach do you recommend to use yeah so
so I kind of mentioned that quickly
during the presentation but the main
difference is that with capture based
approaches you're using probes to pull
down the the region
of interest this this approach tends to
be more expensive and it tends to
require a lot more DNA than an amplicon
based approach or PC a multiplex pcr
based approach but again if you have a
large targets I'd like if you're looking
at an exome type of of sequencing
reaction you definitely need to use the
recapture based approach because the
multiplex pcr based approach is not
going to be as good for large regions
but if your region is less than one mega
base I definitely recommend the
multiplex pcr based approach lets you
know okay and your next question
concerns variants and the question is
what type of areas can need to check
with this enrichment approach and is it
for human DNA only so the the approach
that we have developed so far is for
human DNA only and what you can do what
you could use this approach for is to
look at in tips or or mutations you can
look at insertions and deletions of up
to i would say 40 basis or so and you
can look at also copy number variants
but you unfortunately you cannot use
this approach to look at let's say
rearrangements or fusions see your next
question picking up can you build a
panel for hot spots only sure so if none
of the catalog panels fit your needs you
can use the custom our custom offering
to build to build a panel that fits your
own requirements and needs you can you
can tell that custom builder to you know
to build a panel for hot spots you can
ask it to to build a panel only for
specific exons of specific genes you can
you can target intronic regions you can
target promoter region it basically
takes in any genomic inputs as long as
you can define them on a chromosome by a
start in a stop position you can build
you can build a panel that could be
because for for hot spots it could be
four exons it could be for entire coding
regions of a gene it could be for the
entire gene itself again as long as you
can define that region within
by a on a chromosome by a start and stop
position very useful what types of
coverage do you recommend the depth of
coverage is going to depend on the
application if you are interested in
looking at drumline mutations you know
200 x is more than enough to to look at
germline mutations but if you're looking
at somatic mutations especially those
low frequency mutations you definitely
want to go up to at least 1,500 x across
the targeted regions in order to call
these to accurately call those low
frequency mutations or somatic mutations
ok and then how much DNA can you get
from a liquid biopsy that's going to
depend on on I guess the individual
generally speaking when when you look at
what what researchers have been able to
obtain if you're looking at a healthy
individual you're not going to get a
whole lot of DNA you might be able to
get a total of maybe ten nanograms from
like a 7 ml draw blood blood draw but if
you're looking at a with a with an
advanced disease for instance you can
get you can get maybe 40 or 50 nanograms
of DNA great ok we have time for one
last question an audience member asked
what are the market shares were whole
genome externally and target sequencing
the market share mm-hmm um so so that
also depends on on which sort of class
of customers you're looking at you know
when we definitely when when we look at
the sort of the discovery side of
science we definitely see a lot more
genome and excellent type of approach is
being used but when we look at sort of
on the on the clinical research side we
definitely see smaller smaller panels
being used so more targeted DNA
sequencing you know the exact numbers
I'm not I'm not clear about but I can
definitely tell you on the
clinical research side you definitely
see a lot more targeted DNA sequencing
based being done but then when you look
at the discovery site of research he
definitely seemed more genome and Exum
type of approaches that's fantastic but
like once the m2 thank you ran for this
presentation is really fantastic you
have any further comment for us no again
I think there's there's always going to
be questions about which approach I you
know 11 should take and again it depends
on what you want to do more discovery
requires more information and you know
maybe the whole genome or whole exome
approach is more appropriate but if you
already know what you want to look at I
definitely recommend a targeted DNA
sequencing approach and the content you
know the content is never going to
satisfy one content is never going to
satisfy the needs of everyone but that's
why we've built or we have the mix and
match offering as well as the custom
offering to give you the flexibility to
build your own content that meets your
own needs well thank you once again and
thank you to our sponsor no kaijin
molecular diagnostics for making this
possible to bring this presentation to
you today's webcast will be available Oh
today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing through August of 2016
you will receive an email alerting us
when it's available in on demand and
posted on lab routes comm you're welcome
to forward this announcements any
colleagues who weren't able to join in
today thank you guys and for logging in
and participating in today's live
broadcast see you next time
you
you